IT'S TIME TO PLAY "CRYMALL."
WAIT A MINUTE, THOUGH.
LADIES AND GENTLEMAN, IT GIVES
ME GREAT PLEASURE TO REPORT THAT
OUR LONG NATIONAL NIGHTMARE IS
OVER BECAUSE SKYMALL IS BACK!
( CHEERS AND APPLAUSE )
WE WANT TO HONOR THE MOST
EXCITING THING TO DO ON A PLANE
IF YOUR PHONE IS DEAD AND YOU
DON'T HAVE A BOOK AND YOU'RE
BORED OF CHEWING ON YOUR COLD
SORE.
I'M GOING TO SHOW YOU A PRODUCT
FROM SKYMALL.COM AND FOR 250
POINTS I WANT YOU TO GIVE ME A
TAGLINE TO HELP SELL IT.
FIRST UP, THIS GLOW-IN-THE-DARK
TOILET SEAT
FELICIA.
>> IT'S LIKE HAVING A RAVE
FOREVER YOUR BUTT.
>>Chris: JANET
>> FIND OUT WHAT IT'S LIKE TO
POOP INSIDE TRON.
( CHEERS AND APPLAUSE )
>> Chris: SORRY I GOTTA GO
DELETE A FEW BITS OF
INFORMATION.
NEXT ONE:
THE STATUE OF MARCELLUS
FELICIA.
>> A SKETCHY GUY IN YOUR BUSHES
IN A CLASSY WAY.
>> Chris: YES, YEAH.
FOR ONLY 200 BUCKS, TOO.
( APPLAUSE )
CLUTCH: KEEPER OF THE MYSTIC ORB
JANET.
>> MIGHT AS WELL BITE.
YOU'RE NOT GETTING LAID ANYWAY.
( CHEERS AND APPLAUSE )
>> PERFECT FOR GUARDING YOUR
GLOW-IN-THE-DARK TOILET SEAT.
>> Chris: YES, POINTS.